a few years ago my friend Eric and I
heard about an underwater cave
supposedly full of treasure from the
gold rush we didn't have any money or
fancy tools to explore it so we decided
to build our own DIY submarine mobile
for help we turned to the Internet and
we got feedback from everywhere it was
overwhelming I was never a technical
person but all of a sudden this project
had opened up a new world for me without
realizing it we were building something
here we are two guys in a garage
following nothing but our own curiosity
creating a global community of the most
unlikely ocean explorers we never
actually found any gold in that cave but
I think we found something much more
valuable that exploration isn't just
reserved for a few special people
exploration is accessible to everyone
[Music]